big story all of the major sports teams
have postponed ur schedules because of
the corona virus this includes the
Olympics that's right the 2020 Olympics
were supposed to be held in Japan this
summer
they've been postponed now till at least
2021 I wanted to find out how this was
impacting just a typical Olympic athlete
so I contacted one
his name's Gary Monson he's a four-time
bronze medal winner for the US
gymnastics team and he's joining us
right now Gary
Gary are you there
hey hey hey : hi oh hey Gary could I
catch you in the middle of a workout oh
I just say Jar cocktail sauce yeah
wait you're out of breath because you
were opening a jar of cocktail sauce I'm
trying to this I still can't get it open
it's stupid jar now you must be pretty
disappointed that the Summer Olympics
has been postponed to 2021 oh no
actually I'm kind of relieved because I
feel a little bit behind on my training
and I never really got my act together
so yeah I was I didn't want to say
anything but I'm just gonna say it now
for an Olympic gymnast you seem a little
bit out of shape you you're you really
you're a gymnast though right
yeah of course Sam there's a photo of me
competing check it out Wow okay just
curious Gary when was that picture taken
three weeks ago yeah right before I went
to quarantine
wait a minute that was taken just before
quarantine yeah yeah you know when
you're just sitting around the house
watching TV all day gaining weight is
it's actually pretty easy you'd be
surprised
I just don't understand how did you put
on that much weight in three weeks
forget forget the jar forget the jar the
jar it's inside the jar and there's the
jar won't open so hence the sauce is
inside the jar it's my understanding the
problem correctly yeah cuz there's a jar
in the way No yeah we know right listen
I just don't understand how you managed
to put this kind of weight on so quickly
what have you been eating all of it
eating all of it I mean come on man
it takes a six-pack of beer just to get
through the morning news so the news has
he that stressed out yeah the news is
stressing me out
but lately so is everything else I
watched three episodes of chopped this
afternoon and went through two pints of
ice cream oh it's so stressful Connor
how are they gonna make
all those crazy ingredients and last
night I watched shits Creek so stressful
wait a minute that's a wonderful show
and people it's just a joyous comedy why
is that stressful it was the series
finale Conan it's over six seasons Oh No
the jar down down with the jar okay
the cocktail sauce is in the jar home I
know I understand
Gary hang on who I'm gonna leave you now
okay and I'm just gonna say that I'm
glad that the Olympics have been
postponed and I actually I hope they
you're not on until 2024 you don't seem
like you're ready at all yeah I think I
think you might have a point calling and
you know I think if I just get back to
my training and you don't really put my
mind to it I could probably get back
into shape are you opening that jar
again I'm so hard but it's stuck
Gary monthlies poor [ __ ] sauce
please come to the phone
former athlete Gary Munson lost is mine